j'envie commencé en disant que le riz
graf ce sont des centaines de millions
d'euros que le gouvernement s'apprête à
imputer à l'outre-mer les élus sont
formels les mesures prévues dans le
projet budgétaire 2010 neuf risque de
mettre à mal le tissu économique des dom
tom
si du pouvoir d'achat qui sera par
contre dans le circuit qui sera moins ce
cd taxe d'habitation qui ne vont pas
trop que yi parce qu'on pourra plus
construire comme avant pourra plus
acheter comme avant on tapisse et les
classes moyennes qui ont encore la
possibilité de consommer de construire
de reparler de de verser en tout cas des
contributions au pouvoir d'achat qui
contribuent aux finances des communes y
compris par le biais du poignet hier
c'est dans les rues de fort-de-france
que quelques citoyens représentants
politiques et économiques du pays
déambulaient pour dénoncer la
suppression de l'aide à l'amélioration
de l'habitat
ils ont déposé une motion à la
préfecture
et comme si cela ne suffisait pas les
distilleries n'échappons pas non plus
aux mesures une taxe de 3 euros 15 sur
le rhum et en propositions de loi en
clair la bouteille de 75 centilitres
devrait subir une augmentation de deux
euros cinquante ne pas claquer française
c'est le deuxième exportateur
après l'aéronautique en martinique le
2ème exportateur c'est le rhum est donc
aujourd'hui contre touche le rhum on
touche à toute l'économie de la
martinique
quand on touche aux roms on touche au
tourisme on ne comprend pas cette mesure
radicale réforme de l'abattement fiscal
de 30 % suppression de la tva non payées
crédit d'impôt également supprimés selon
l'économiste michel branchi ces mesures
auront des répercussions terribles dans
tous les secteurs les effets c'est en
effet des mauriciens nous avons déjà un
pib qui a du mal à tenir la route en
avant là on vient d'avoir le chiffre de
2010 est c02 bon sens et danse dans ce
assez les six ans publique et
l'investissement public qui a diminué
c'est surtout le fait qu'on a diminué
les dotations aux collectivités locales
le collectif de l'eau car c'est
essentiellement le soutien social à la
population il ya un sentiment qui m'a
les parlementaires d outre-mer sont à
pied d'oeuvre
ils sont fédérées ils veulent trouver le
moyen d'empêcher ces mesures de voir le
jour c'est rare de voir une telle
mobilisation
et puis de recevoir des réponses qui
sont de réponse humiliante et ce n'est
pas gagné